We, the CDU,
are the European party,
because our chancellors have the course for 1.
Europe placed in security and peace.
Conrad Adenauer,
the 1.
German has appointed the European Community for
reconciliation with the Netherlands,
France and Belgium.
Helmukohl,
the chancellor of German unification has overcome not only
the division of Germany but all of Europe.
It is about the freedom of the one Europe.
We first took care of the aussöne and peace,
then of economic cooperation and thus the economic interests all united.
The reconstruction of the economy and the creation of
a common market have led Europe to prosperity.
Our goal for Europe always knows and still is war to
prevent chaos and communist gewaltenherrschaften .
Our goal was and is to replace these things with a liberal,
pluralistic basic order and democracy and legally strongness in Europe.
We succeeded and we are proud of that.
We will continue not to let anti-authoritarian forces destroy
our Europe - its from the left or from the right.
Christian Democrats have always successfully advocated diversity
and prosperity in Europe over the past decades.
And that is exactly what we will continue to do for the future of Europe.
We have always assumed social and political responsibility and
that is precisely why the CDU is the party of Europe.
And it should stay that way.
And that is why you too vote for the CDU.